BIOLOGICAL GRANDMOTHER, DONNA,
AND BIOLOGICAL AUNT DEBBIE
BROOKS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING WITH
ME.
THIS IS FANTASTIC NEWS AFTER ALL
OF THIS TIME SHE HAS BEEN FOUND.
DONNA, LET ME START WITH YOU.
I UNDERSTAND THAT YOU HAVEN'T
FACE TO FACE BEEN WITH YOUR
GRANDDAUGHTER, BUT YOU HAVE NOW
SEEN HER.
TELL ME ABOUT THAT MOMENT.
>> WELL, IT WAS A REALLY GREAT
MOMENT.
ALL KINDS OF FEELINGS COMES TO
YOU.
LOOKING AT HER, AND I REMEMBER
HOLDING HER AS A LITTLE BABY,
AND I WAS JUST OVERWHELMED, YOU
KNOW, AND I WANTED TO JUST JUMP
UP AND HUG HER BUT YOU CAN'T
BECAUSE YOU'RE DOING THE ZOOM,
YOU KNOW.
SO MAYBE EVENTUALLY IN PERSON.
>> YOU TAKE ONE LOOK AT HER, AND
YOU CAN TELL SHE'S DEFINITELY
FAMILY.
>> SHE'S DEFINITELY FAMILY.
YOU CAN DEFINITELY SEE IT.
>> SO YOU KNEW THE FIRST MOMENT
THAT YOU SAW.
HAVE YOU PLANNED WHEN YOU WILL
BE REUNITED, WHEN YOU'LL BE BACK
TOGETHER?
>> WELL, I KNOW THAT WE'RE
TRYING TO PUT SOMETHING
TOGETHER.
RIGHT NOW I DON'T THINK SHE'S
READY.
SHE JUST FOUND OUT ON THE 7th,
WHICH WAS MY BROTHER'S BIRTHDAY,
ABOUT HER PARENTS, AND THAT
SHE'S GOT THIS HUGE EXTENSIVE
FAMILY WHEN SHE THOUGHT SHE WAS
AN ONLY CHILD.
AND SO I THINK A LITTLE
OVERWHELMING, SHE'S STILL
PROCESSING EVERYTHING.
WE DON'T WANT TO PUSH OURSELVES
ON HER UNTIL SHE'S READY.
>> DEBBIE, WE UNDERSTAND HOW
YOUR BROTHER AND YOUR
SISTER-IN-LAW, THEY WERE
CONFIRMED, THEIR BODIES, THEIR
IDENTITIES AFTER 40 YEARS.
BUT HOW DID THEY CONNECT YOUR
NIECE, BABY HOLLY, TO THE
COUPLE, TO HER PARENTS?
>> WELL, THE -- I'M NOT SURE HOW
YOU PRONOUNCE IT, NCMEC IT IS.
THEY HAVE BEEN HEAVILY INVOLVED
WITH THE DETECTIVES IN TRYING TO
FIND HER.
SO WE HAD MENTIONED ABOUT, YOU
KNOW, SHE WAS BORN IN NEW SMYRNA
IN FISH HOSPITAL AT NEW SMYRNA
BEACH, FLORIDA, AND THE
DETECTIVES TRIED TO GET THAT
BIRTH CERTIFICATE BUT THEY
COULDN'T BECAUSE IT HAD BEEN
SEALED IF YOU WILL.
THEY HAD TO GO THROUGH A LOT OF
RED TAPE, IF YOU WILL, TO GET IT
UNSEALED.
ONCE THEY GOT IT UNSEALED, THEN
THEY SAW THAT THERE WAS AN
ADOPTION ATTACHED TO IT.
ONCE THEY SAW THE ADOPTION THAT
WAS ATTACHED TO IT, THEN THEY
WERE ABLE TO TRACK DOWN WHO
ADOPTED HER, AND THAT'S HOW WE
FOUND HER.
>> DONNA, 40 YEARS THAT YOUR
GRANDDAUGHTER HAS BEEN MISSING.
DID YOU BELIEVE THAT SHE WAS
STILL ALIVE, THAT SHE WAS STILL
OUT THERE SOMEWHERE AND YOU
WOULD BE ABLE TO FIND HER?
>> I JUST KEPT PRAYING AND
HOPING, AND NEVER GAVE UP HOPE
AND BELIEVING IN THE LORD THAT
HE WOULD REVEAL IT TO ME
EVENTUALLY.
I ASKED HIM TO LET ME KNOW WHAT
HAPPENED TO MY SON AND HIS WIFE
AND